the students spend about six hours in
class each week and right at the
beginning of the semester most of those
six hours are the lectures or activities
or workshops that we have planned to
have inside the class is very very
tightly programmed this may involve a
brainstorming for the team projects or
forming up with teams going through the
project constraints or teaching them the
techniques that we want them to learn
near the end of the semester we heavily
scale back the program content we give
students a lot of class time just to
meet up with the teams because for many
many teams it's difficult enough to
gather you know six people in the same
room in the same place at the same time
to get eight of them in the same room
well if you're doing it during class
time at least you know everybody's gonna
be there so so we try to give as much
time as possible later in the semester
for teams to actually work on their
project
but sometimes that is planned out like
later sessions for instance where
students play each other's games the
first half of the semester is all the
lecture in the workshops are given by by
the staff but by the second half of the
semester we're getting them to see other
aspects of game development so within
MIT students and actually this year a
few Wellesley students most of our
students are gonna be coming to us with
a programming background a few might
have some design classes under the belt
maybe they've taken one of our game
design classes or another design class
offered at MIT
some of the students are gonna have some
art aptitude unfeasible art aptitude so
I'm a little bit more on sound design or
music composition aptitude but for the
most part they don't know what it's like
to be an artist they don't know what
it's like to be a sound designer on a
game development project and they might
actually not know anything about the
business of games so the last half of
the semester is bringing in guest
lectures from the industry we've got a
great network here in Boston an
independent game developer network also
quite a few of the triple a larger
studios are here so we mine our network
and each year we get new speakers to
come talk to them about
how to work with an artist how to work
with a sound designer what it actually
means to be an art director in a in a
game company or what it actually doesn't
mean to even be a level designer on a
large project but then also we're
bringing people in to talk about
business models Kickstarter is often an
interesting topic for the students
things we try to balance it between
here's what the industry looks like and
here's the things are gonna help you
right now with the big game that you're
working on now and if you wanted to take
the game a little bit further after the
course here's the things that you could
do things like fundraising submitting it
to festivals marketing it and things I'm
just getting other people to play it